[Music]
today i'm going to show you
how to clean trees kitchen
this kitchen has been not cleaned
for three years
in this kitchen there was lot of grease
and food kitchen sink was
full of smelly water but i think
i have hailstones it's like a
really tiny rock they are melting all
the organic
things like food hair
stuff like that
[Music]
after that i washed the dishes there
there was also a lot of calcium calcium
comes from
the water and you remove it acid
like citric acid
here i have a knife and there is
triad butter so i have to use scraper
for that
for the sink i use scrub mommy
and dish brush i'm
always using scrap daddy because i think
their sponges are the best ones and i
have
tried many sponges
usually if the sink is really uh dirty
i use always oven cleaner i think that's
the best
product for grease stains on cleaners p
ph scale is like 12.
this soap is like seven it's neutral
but oven cleaner is highly alkaline
product so it's super effective for
grease stains
there is a lot of dried and burnt food
and a lot of trees
there i have added oven cleaner and then
i'm brushing it with dish brush
usually in the kitchen there is like
a lot of grease and then crease
collects like the dust so it squeeze
and dust mixed
i think it's built up like that because
the house owner never bites it
[Music]
people usually forget to clean on their
kitchen
the cabinets because it's a lot of work
to get out
the stuff and clean there and
the top chill there is a lot of grease
and stuff like that
people usually clean what they see like
this area but down there and
up there they feel good here i have
contour top
i'm adding oven cleaner there and then i
have
this brush then i'm only brushing it
there i have coffee stains and coffee
is like grease coffee has oil on it
so that's why the oven cleaner works
typically there is two kinds of stains
soft stains and hard stains
soft stains are like grease oil
stickings for the soft stains
you will need highly alkaline solutions
like oven cleaner or this water
detergent and heart stains
are like calcium rust things like that
and for them heart stains you will need
acid like ph scale one
or two calcium stains
are like white and hard
but trees and oil they are like sticky
you will need to know which one stain
you have if i have calcium stains
and you use it the strongest possible
autoline solution
it won't do nothing it doesn't work
so that's why you need to know which one
you have
then you can choose your products
[Music]
i clean up only for free because people
who can buy cleaning they don't like
need it i want to help those who cannot
afford it
i help everybody that i'm able to
sometimes people send me pictures from
their home
but they are too clean and too clean
it's
boring boring so if i see mess
i'm like yes i'm coming right away